we are delighted to welcome back to Yale
Minister Gareth Evans he has covered the
waterfront of Australian politics
starting off as a student leader he
became the first cabinet minister in
1993 as the Attorney General then he
occupied several ministerial position
and his last minstrel position he held
on Minister external affairs which he
concluded in 1996 and since then he has
done many things but most importantly he
has been the chairman on CEO of
International Crisis Group very famous
in non-governmental organisation today
which covers the more than 60 countries
and prevents the world prevent that sort
of warns the world of work remain crisis
and it has it is a great pleasure to
welcome you back to Yale Minister Evans
to let it be back you know it so you
have just published a book which is has
a rather unlikely title from a grizzled
diplomat and public official like you
and indeed the book does show that you
are an incorrigible optimist without
that optimism
you couldn't have carried out this long
public carrier that you have had so
maybe you can start off by saying what
is the origin of this optimism
well of course always looking on the
bright side does lend itself to parody
as fans of monty python won't need any
reminding but i have been an optimist
essentially for a combination of
objective and subjective reasons the
objective reasons that when you look at
the great sweep of history we really can
see the positives as being the dominant
story the dramatic decline in the number
of people in poverty I mean 700 million
alone in the last two decades in China
we can see a dramatic decline in the
incidence of violence both across
countries within countries domestically
yes there are some terrible spikes and
terrible bumps and we're seeing them of
course now in Syria and Yemen and we're
seen reinjure crisis in men and of
course if you're consumed by the daily
headlines it's very difficult to be
optimistic about anything but if you do
look at that sweep of history you see
the decline steven pinker at harvard has
talked about this Nicholas Kristof in
the New York Times writes about this
every year that this was really the best
year in human history whatever else
seems to have gone wrong simply because
of the number of people no longer amiss
Erised by grinding poverty so there's
that objective story and the fact that
of the individual things that are going
wrong no doubt some of which we'll talk
about North Korea and elsewhere I do
think there are solutions that are
achievable with the right combination of
goodwill but the the psychological
reason is in many ways the more
important one I really do believe that
if you want to make the world a better
place you've got to believe that that's
possible if you don't believe that
anything you do is going to make much of
a difference if you are a congenital
pessimist you just don't get out a bit
in the morning when it comes to working
on these big public policy issues so I
think that both pessimism and optimism
are self reinforcing they're not self
fulfilling but they're self reinforcing
and I believe as I say in the book
quoting someone at the beginning better
to live your life as an optimist and be
periodically proved quite wrong than to
live your life as a pessimist and always
be right but you are in some ways your
optimism is surprising given something
very shocking episodes you have
witnessed in your life oh yeah including
the for your moving story of your
Aboriginal friend young person who
commits suicide and so and you have been
a champion of racial equality and human
rights and so who do you ascribe these
experiences to that desire for you to
yeah well it's why you are as you are as
a combination I think of your innate
instincts your genetic makeup but also
your life experiences and I've had many
many kinds of experience both good and
bad but you know the wake-up calls that
come when you experience the
psychological debilitation of
Australia's Aboriginal people with a
kind which led my young friend to commit
suicide and horrible circumstances
that's a wake-up call when it comes to
any kind of complacency about the policy
issues involved why am i I mean at all
optimistic about the condition of
Indigenous Australians when so much is
still not going right well because we
have made the apology to the Stolen
Generation people and very moving in
graphic terms Australian Government's
successively now have taken
responsibility and apologize for taking
away youngsters from their their
families for perhaps the best of
motivations at the time but with the
worst of consequences I am optimistic
about the effect of recognising as we
now do in Australia prior indigenous
ownership of the land which for many
decades was just a matter of denial for
white Australians white Australian
government so Aboriginal land rights
indigenous land rights are very much
part now the tapestry and a very
dignifying dimension of the now the
Aboriginal experience so everywhere you
look there's the things that have gone
horribly bad the things that move you
and impact you but then you get out and
try and do something about them or work
with governments that do or with the
international community and I do see
enough progress in enough places to make
me continuingly
optimistic even though obviously
elevation of someone like Donald Trump
is a is a bit of a wake-up call for all
of us and challenge to all of us but for
all of that I think it's important to to
just keep looking at how you move the
game forward rather than thinking about
the inevitability of lack of progress we
will come back to that but just I wanted
to
teller are they and suppose to episodes
you described in your book as they serve
a young student not many politicians I
know who have reached your stature and
who have throw backpack through Asia and
seen like in the raw and your experience
in Vietnam in war-torn Vietnam he
arrived in Saigon and what you witness
and he didn't go to India in a crowded
train in third class compartment your
encounter with humanity these are the
two things you can perhaps quickly tell
our audience well these are two of the
really formative experiences for me in
Vietnam I just arrived middle of the war
curiosity driving me into a lunatic
Enterprise of seeing what was happening
in Saigon not exactly set up for tourism
I finally found a way of hitching a ride
into the city eventually found a hotel
that I could afford which manifestly
wasn't set up for sleeping
it was squalid in the extreme filthy
sheet cigarette butts on the floor I
came in I was looking around thinking
what am I got myself into well the very
first thing that happened there was a
commotion and the landing outside and a
great big American GI was building a
half-naked Vietnamese girl with a
broomstick down the stairs and that just
encapsulated in an instant the horror
the misery you know the humiliation that
is associated really with any any war
between anyone anywhere and it made me
really understand just in a way that
reading everything about the Vietnam
conflict had not really brought home to
me so that was one experience the other
experience was just a completely
different kind of experience traveling
around in third-class trains in India as
a young student on my way to Oxford from
Australia as you say and on one such
occasion I think it was down in the
middle of India traveling from sanchita
Jan co-occur remember and in a very very
crowded train with my cardboard suitcase
and backpack and everybody on top of
everyone else and a blind beggar got
into the Train at one of the stations
singing to the compartment and then
bringing his his cup around
obviously tried to survive I had a big
clunky tape recorder with me which I was
recording the site of the sounds of
India and unbeknown to him I recorded
him while he was singing and as he was
handing around his tin cup I'd played
that recording back his first reaction
was one of incredible anger there's
someone else there's someone else on my
patch in this train he'd never heard his
own voice before and they the passengers
calmed him down calm down yes listen
this is you and the most wonderful
beatific smile you know breakout I mean
just just to watch this guy very old man
hearing himself and recognising for the
first time what it was and that was just
a magical moment I think of just and and
the rest of the trip I mean he's saying
we played it back he's saying we played
it back in the hole there's the spirit
of twenty odd people in that carriage
crowded around this guy all experiencing
this the surge of common humanity so
it's a much better story to tell when
you go to be diplomatic dinners than the
usual story and II have been to many
that he cannot obviously count how many
but one of the things that you have done
of many things we have done in Asia is
your role in bringing the ASEAN
countries together and the international
community to find peace in Cambodia so
this was that was a very big challenge
that Cambodia this was we're talking
about the late 80s the Khmer Rouge had
been pushed out by one sends Vietnam
backed administration to the margins of
the country but civil war were still
waging they were still nearly 400,000
people refugees displaced on the border
the country was in a condition of total
misery and was incredibly divided
internally the political factions
communist non-communist all hated each
other
Vietnam and the ASEAN countries the time
hated each other
joseon's were were supporting the
non-communist scénic regime the
Vietnamese were supporting once in the
great powers were all
so lined up the Chinese behind the Khmer
Rouge the Russians behind the Vietnamese
and the Americans behind the Communists
as e'en so bringing all that you're
finding away through it was that was the
great challenge of the 1980s and
Australia during my term as foreign
minister was able to take a leading role
in this because we we basically came up
with the concept of a major role for the
UN in the transitional period an
unprecedentedly central role for the UN
in which it wouldn't just do election
monitoring that would actually
administer the country take over the
executive responsibilities the critical
dimension of this in bringing the peace
that then was finally negotiated was
that this role for the UN gave China a
face-saving
way of stepping back from support from
the Khmer Rouge you can explain the
complex dynamics in many other ways but
that was the key that then created the
conditions where a genuine consensual
solution could be found and we succeeded
we brought peace to Hamburg and that we
didn't bring democracy and human rights
um yes that's another story
and in this you got an unusual support
from the American congressman Steve
Soler yes
the original idea to for that central
role for the u.s. didn't come from me it
came from Steve Soliz who very well
known around the region he hadn't really
thought through how it might be
operationalized he had this dawn of an
idea and he told me when I met him in
New York UN meeting that he'd been
trying to flog the idea among the
American political establishment the
policy community and they don't know all
told him is talking nonsense that the UN
had no business in this it was going to
be resolved in some other way some other
time so he came to me and said can you
turn this into something and I think we
did one of the other factors of course
was the fantastic support of the
Indonesians and Ally a latests
my my comrade-in-arms as foreign
minister we worked incredibly closely
together and I think you know Australia
recognized in which many countries would
do well to recognize that sometimes your
biggest achievements can come from not
thrusting yourself onto a sense
stage but working through others so
although we did really gigantic amount
of the work and thinking through and
operationalizing how this plan to come
together was using a Loyola Terrace as
the chairman the co-chair of the
International Conference and as Ian's
key foreign minister that was the key to
that success and I think in terms of the
the current task we have in bringing
together an increasingly fragmented and
four super us as en that role of
Indonesia is going to be really crucial
it is to your credit that you got Alex
Alex Allie Allison Allison involving
East Timor oh yeah why are your
relations with in Russia we're in the
pits
yeah well popular opinion in Australia
was very hostile to Indonesia and I was
no enthusiast for Indonesia's role in
1975 which was really pretty disgraceful
the military occupation the seizure of
his team war but it was a reality which
then none of us thought was capable of
being changed the later events and late
90s came as a surprise I think to to
everybody but that's a different story
back in that period the common cause
that Ali our TAS and I had were to try
to work together to find a solution a
workable solution the East Timor problem
which would recognize the or genuine
autonomy still within an Indonesian
sovereign framework but autonomy get the
military out get aid in get cultural
language recognition as part of the
terrain and just generally have a firm
or civilized approach my friend and
colleague Alan test was absolutely on
board for that and we worked very well
together what's time unit actually was
because he was just on the point of
persuading President Suharto that this
is what had to be done this was the the
pebble in the shoe of Indonesia's
relationships not only with Australia
but with the rest of the world it was
doing damage and Indonesia had to step
back from this authoritarian military
role
unfortunately what killed it was
a classic example of what can go wrong
and in public diplomacy Bill Clinton US
president in the lead-up to the APEC
asia-pacific Economic Cooperation
meeting scheduled to be held in Bogor
and Indonesia in 94 actually overtly
made a big public speech in which she
said Indonesia has to move on East Timor
has to grant autonomy this is in
possible situation that's depressing is
debilitating Indonesia has to act and
Suharto who up until then had been
prepared to act just reacted very very
any last night to that extreme form of
public pressure leverage being put in
music go to hell I'm not going to do I'm
not going to move and nothing nothing
happened which is one of one of my great
disappointments but but also the
massacred in Dili all the best security
well massacre and Dooley was it was was
just a terrible shock to a low test I
broke the news to Ehlert s do your inter
parent career I think at a meeting
together the news came in overnight and
I heard it earlier than he did and his
face just went absolutely white which is
because he knew was indefensible he knew
that the military had once again got
completely out of control but he did a
sure me and I totally believed him that
this was not a matter of a central
direction exercise this was just a rogue
excessive military behavior of the kind
of it so often seen this got me into
more political trouble and I think many
other things did during my tenure as
foreign minister because I actually said
in a public statement I'm sure this was
not a deliberate act of Indonesian state
policy it was a matter of the military
once again careering out of control we
ought to recognize that in the way in
which we mount a reaction and absolutely
condemned a tree and of course those
responsible must be brought to book but
don't treat this as cause for breakdown
in Australia Indonesia relation
unfortunately diplomatic and political
life is not quite as subtle as that and
I was pilloried for my abominable
embrace of the evil Indonesians but
madness that's life
however you might denounce you you
actually contributed much to the
alphabet so of ASEAN you are involved in
creating a RF well the patient doesn't
regional for oranges a dialogue body on
conflict issues and I was also centrally
involved in the creation of APEC the
asia-pacific Economic Cooperation forum
both of which are I think important
policy dialogue mechanisms which do have
a continuing life I think the other in
regional forum the security one has been
rather disappointing and the impact that
it's made and I think it's functions are
now largely being subsumed into the new
East Asian for me a East Asian he says
yes at which you do have both yeah
political and economic issues being
addressed at that leadership level but
no as Ian's still tremendously important
conflict prevention vehicle as the
European Union has traditionally been
and states that constantly niggling and
at war the risk of violent conflict with
each other have learned to live together
but as Ian are certainly punching below
its weight in terms of its collective
capacity to produce you know good
behavior in cases like Myanmar at the
moment and so on and as he will be
struggling to offer any kind of
effective counterweight to to China what
I come to but before I come to ASEAN and
China I would like to hear your views on
ASEAN and Chinese delicious with
Australia recently there have been a lot
of debate in Australia about a one in a
village ability of Australia's siding
with China because of this deep economic
cooperation and China size and other
hand the Chinese word attempt to
influence Australian public opinion
politics is creating a lot of anger and
opposition so where do you stand on that
issue
well Australia is not very different
from most of the other countries in the
region
who simultaneously are huge economic
partners of China biggest partner and
that's the case for most of the other
countries in Southeast Asia and at the
same time relying traditionally for our
security or on American alliance or
partnership relationships or dominance
in the region and all of us want to
avoid desperately a kind of zero-sum
game developing in which we will have to
choose between security partners and our
economic partners we don't want that to
happen
China is seen in many circles as engaged
at the moment in a lot of chest beating
and wing-flapping and perhaps overreach
South China Sea some of the other things
that's doing and in terms of the way in
which it has been caught out trying to
exercise influence through various
intermediaries on Australian politicians
I don't think we should be too spooked
by this I mean China is not behaving
differently from any other rising power
it's got the centuries of humiliation
behind it it's got decades of being
treated even while its rise was becoming
obvious there's still a rule taker
rather than a rule maker in the global
order I mean as recently as the end of
the Obama administration the wonderful
Obama administration Barack Obama is
saying in the context of the
trans-pacific trade partnership we make
the rules China's not going to make the
rules we make the rule so it's not
surprising the China should be being
rather more assertive in wanting to play
itself into the game and I don't think
we're seeing anything in Australia or
anywhere else that should alarmist to
the point of wanting to breach the
relationship or run back to Washington
particularly not in Washington's current
mood of disengagement and quite erratic
response to all these issues I think
it's perfectly capable that China will
play a constructive role in the regional
and the global order and will be
committed and be an effective producer
of global and regional public goods I
mean look at the way it is behaving on
the climate issue yes there's a bit of
Nicoll opportunism involved and moving
in to fill the space that the Americans
have left look at the way it's talking
the talk on trade policy and so on
yes maybe a bit of cynicism there but on
the whole if we can if we can tap the
better angels of the Chinese nature
their desire to be an active part of a
cooperative global and regional
community I don't think we need to worry
too much we do have to just one more
point we do have to push back I think
when it gets over assertive as it has
been in the South China Sea with its
occupancy of these islets and reefs and
the building of effectively military
installations I don't think that is in
breach of the international rule book
and I don't think we should just accept
it I think they should do the navigation
operations and all the rest of it which
makes clear that this is going to firm
you said that you supported the
Australian policy of freedom of
navigation operations going within 12
miles of these islets are reefs but at
the same time you also say in your book
that you are you don't like the idea of
us claiming dominance or well it took
the two separate issues I mean they the
responding to the Chinese overreach
ought to be not just a u.s. thing or an
Australian thing that ought to be an
Indonesian thing a Malaysian thing a
Vietnamese thing we ought to be
cooperatively engaged in that push back
because China will be all too
comfortable in pushing the envelope and
recreating by default those hedge
emmonak relationships those tributary
relationships that are traditionally
enjoyed with the countries of the region
where everybody count down
I don't think China wants to push the
envelope violently but it will go just
as far as it can when it's not when its
comfort zone is not not challenged so
that's important on the larger issue I
think it is time for America to
recognize that China is a very very beat
player globally regionally and that the
traditional p-word primacy predominance
preeminence
the D word dominance these words are
just no longer an appropriate way of
describing either what is possible or
what is desirable the most sensible
thing I ever heard said on the us-china
relationship was by Bill Clinton two
years after he left the presidency and
was in private meeting it wasn't in a
public forum and he never ever used
hello he came close to it in Yale a
couple of years later actually at a
public event but not using these words
which to me were very graphic what I
heard Clinton say sharing a platform
with him was there are two choices
America faces and how we use this great
and unrivaled military and economic
power that we have choice number one is
to use that huge military and economic
power to try to stay top dog top dog on
the global Block in perpetuity choice
number two is to create a world in which
we will be comfortable living when we
are no longer top dog on the global
block I thought that was pitch perfect
not something that people even now I
feel comfortable saying in American
public life because you never want to
accept that America will be anything
other than unchallenged number one but
the reality is those days are over
America has to find some space you have
to look for cooperative solutions to
these problems not dominant solutions
well yeah you have got Donald Trump
who's willing to hand over here to the
Chinese because that's what in really
just happening by withdrawing from TVP
well I don't think he knows what he's
doing he's a creature of instinct rather
than policy judgment he obviously has no
real quality advice around him he's
pushes in one direction on trade in
another direction the next day on
something else nobody in the region
knows what the hell is about except that
there's nothing like the same passionate
commitment to those Alliance
relationships and nothing like the same
commitment to strong continued American
engagement in the region America first
is not if the religion is so
disheartened about the possibility of
American support in case of any threat
to the face wouldn't you be
tell for them to just move towards China
saying that this is our out there are
other options I'm America is going to
stay engaged it has to I mean it's
economically committed there's so much
of the American heart and soul is built
in America is not going to go away it's
but it's going to be one player among
others it's not going to be the the Sun
around which the whole that part of the
world revolves what is important is for
the other countries in the region to
work together cooperatively to build
military working relationships political
diplomatic relationships that do make
common cause against possible Chinese
overreach I'm not talking about a
containment exercise I'm not talking
about anything as vulgar as extreme as
some of the language that's going around
but the relationship that can and should
I think be forged between India which
has interests of its own visa vie China
obviously Australia Indonesia Japan
South Korea Vietnam all of us have a
common interest in ensuring that the
peace and stability the region is
maintained between us we have quite a
lot of clout we have quite a lot of but
you have you have in your book who said
you are not very in favor of the idea of
quarte the so-called
Australia India US when the court idea
was first formulated back in 2007 this
was before we had seen the Chinese in
South China Sea in particular and it was
then a very obvious ideological contain
you know and military containment sort
of operation Australia's it and I know
we we value our relationship with China
we we don't think we need to be as
overtly involved in this and and I was
very very cautious myself and I I
embraced that view as time has gone on
and even even since finishing the book
you know last now nearly a year ago I
suppose when I went to prison I I I do
think I do think it is important that
there be visible cooperation between all
the
significant countries in the region to
make it clear that we all value a
rules-based international order while we
value our economic relations with China
while we don't want to in any way you
know quash China's ambitions strategic
ambitions economic ambitions belt and
Road and all the risks we don't want to
quash it we do think China has a place
in the Sun and in the rulemaking Sun not
just the rule taking short short short
but nonetheless we are not going to sit
idly by and watch a steady encroachment
on sovereignty sorts of issues as the
territorial sea issue is in the South
China Sea without making very clear
where we collectively stand and making
clear our capacity to resist that if
that ever came to it so I don't think I
don't think it will I don't think I
don't think China is in the slightest
bit interest in provoking any kind of a
military confrontation with anybody
about anything maybe India's a little
bit of an exception because of the
border issues and with all the history
but in terms of having a full-scale war
it's the last thing Charlie some would
said that this is exactly what the
Chinese don't want a full-scale conflict
but their policy of salami slicing has
got them what they've got in South China
Sea so Chauncey is now virtually Chinese
Lick and it has been achieved over the
last decade in a slow steady state but
it's not a Chinese like if Australian
ships and Indonesian ships and Malaysian
ships and Vietnamese ships sailing
constantly within what China would like
to claim or its sovereign territorial
waters but which nobody else accepts as
such I mean that's not happening only
Australian and that's that's why I'm
saying it should happen I'm never asking
me where I stand on those issues and why
I think working with our Xion - and the
other countries to achieve a degree of
solidarity on this is very important and
that's one of the things that worries me
a bit is that I mean a couple of rzn
countries are wholly owned subsidiaries
of China or any country after your
friend Han santé I'm afraid Cambodia and
Laos very very disappointing in this
respect so we we've got a lot of work to
- together but I think every everybody
is making common cause here and well the
Chinese are pushing the envelope I mean
I know these guys pretty well I mean I
don't know the current regime and maybe
maybe they've got a different world view
than the Chen Cheech ends and the others
that I spent so much time with and for
whom I had so much respect but at the
end of the day I do think China
naturally wants a place in the strategic
universe as well as the economic
universe which reflects the reality of
its size its achievements in it
separations then we ought to be prepared
to do just that well on that optimistic
note thank you Stevens for talking with
us thank you not always a pleasure thank
you